it's a highlight at the locks open in
Switzerland this halfpipe is 200 meters
long 22 metres wide in almost seven
meters high as a novice on the slope I'm
amazed this is where the best freestyle
snowboarders battle for the title worth
more than four hundred sixty thousand
euros this is the biggest halfpipe ever
for this kind of sport you not only have
to be tough but also a little bit crazy
like the 27 year old Danny Davis from
the United States he's one of the
world's top freestyle snowboard he won
many titles including the gold medal for
half pipe twice he's one of the
favorites here at the locks open what's
so special about snowboarding beside the
cool outfits what's great is it's in our
world it's not supposed to be perfect
it's not a race it's about creative
freedom and snowboarding I want to try
this out would you help me and give me
some advice go to the flat slope you
know and and take your time don't go
fast don't feel you need to like go fast
and do the whole mountain the first day
just take it at your own pace what are
the word thing let us ever happen to you
I've broken bones and things like that
you know so late oh all over femur
ankles yeah it's not a few few injuries
but that's part of the part of the game
well then wish me luck even for
beginners like me locks is a great place
to give this a try there is even a
freestyle Academy down in the valley
Oh
even some pros practice their sounds on
the Academy's 1,000 square meters
without snow of course like me today
finally I get a board under my feet and
it takes me down it's see but the pace
is nice and slow and now for the snow
but here i have a pro by my side notta
cooney the snowboard teacher who we got
me on my first attempt on the snow
consumers to do can also estimate and
3-inch tracking you know that this my
mother's mr. bellows is Saddam treating
maybe you think I was it crazy to try
this out for the first time in my age
but isn't it all about having fun I
think so
okay maybe I don't look very
professional yeah but it's definitely a
lot of fun even if I'm a long way off
from the to test the halfpipe
yeah not so bad for my first dry I have
to show this to my snowboard Idol Danny
Davis maybe he'll have a few more tips
in star with Dennis help I give it a
child that's the turn that's what you
got to learn cuz you can't stay on one
edge the whole time ok gotta be very
close heels toes heels toe yeah and
that's okay to love then you're surfing
and you're not just falling down the
hill thank you be a snowboarder one day
I'm to vonage practice practice practice
Bob there are some situations where even
practice won't help Louella played havoc
with danny davis and the semi-finals he
couldn't show his best side and was
eliminated
japanese high-flyer I you me llega know
who's just 17 years old ended up winning
the locks open 2016 in second and third
place came Patrick bhavana and David huh
Blitzen both a Swiss and train here
often Lutz is the place to be for the
sport but as an absolute beginner I
definitely have my work cut out for me
maybe I can't snow but like a pro but I
can party like one and Apple she is also
part of the game isn't it gorgeous